[Music]  we have a clip of Game of Thrones and  this is exciting because no one's  getting to see a lot of clips of Game of  Thrones yeah we're very excited that you  brought one mmm anything we need to know  for this clip this I believe this is the  first time that you see Sam and Gilly in  the new season at the end of season five  they believe in Castle black to go to  the Citadel and I think this is the  first time you see them in season six  unstable look at this clip from Game of  Thrones I am tell you ACC was called the  C because it was nothing but water as  far as the eye could see I don't think  so  see see different they sound the same  they do it was before I learned how to  read obviously  are you going to be safe in here oh  thank you  [Music]  you